welcome to metaphysical milkshake I am
your co-host Reza Aslin
right hey Reza
and this is the part where you say I'm
your I'm the other co-host oh yeah sorry
I was in the middle of something and I'm
your uh other uh host co-host what are
you Rayne Wilson are you reading in the
middle of the podcast well
listen
um I knew we were going to be talking
about science fiction today so I brought
out some uh just a dozen or so titles
from my collection of hundreds
literally hundreds of science fiction
books um that I collected as a gawky
teenager in the 70s and 80s oh these
books
because these books were literally my
only friends these books and my bassoon
and my chess board were my only friends
technically your soon was your
girlfriend but keep going uh what do you
what do you got there what do you what
do you have uh Ben bova's uh privateers
what else do we have CJ Sherry heavy
time some great some great uh covers
then we go like more into like the 50s
and 60s stuff rendezvous with Rama
they're making a movie do you know
rendezvous with Rama have you read this
one yeah absolutely I have not read it
but I know the book yes classic classic
wow that's a pretty good collection
welcome to metaphysical Milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of Life along
the way presented by Cass media and soul
pancake
you know this is one of the many things
that you and I have in common with each
other so it's like they were both
incredibly handsome and talented thank
you yes um but we both kind of grew up
with sci-fi like sci-fi it was the first
kind of stories that I ever remember
hearing it's the first kind of stories
that I ever remember writing I had like
this very clear memory of when I was in
like I don't know fourth grade or
whatever writing a writing my first
short story and it was like a Sci-Fi
Adventure you know short story
um like sci-fi is kind of how I figured
out who I am and and like what my role
in the world is it informed me of who I
was as well I mean it's my personality
it's my imagination
um I didn't know worlds like this were
possible my life was absolutely Barren
before science fiction I think a
combination of Science Fiction and 70s
and 80s sitcoms kind of uh completely
made me who I am too evidenced by my
life so
um I think that science science fiction
can change the world oh yeah and so we
wanted to discuss this with a a an
incredibly
thoughtful brilliant insightful uh
science fiction uh nerd one of the
biggest on the planet
um his name is Ryan Britt he's got this
book phasers on stun how the making and
remaking of Star Trek changed the world
he's been writing on science fiction and
pop culture since 2009 he was a
entertainment editor at fatherley's
contributed to sci-fi wire and den of
geek and vulture and vice and CNN and on
and on like true certified nerd and you
know what we wanted to talk about I mean
obviously he's written a lot about Star
Trek as you learn about it but what we
wanted to really talk about with him is
this idea that maybe science fiction is
the thing that saves us as a society as
a planet as a civilization can science
fiction save us
Brian Brett welcome to the show phasers
on stun how the making and remaking of
Star Trek changed the world
wait dude Ryan do you know this story
because like you know obviously we've
got you know two huge Star Trek fans
rain as you well know and as we've
discussed you know has is in the Star
Trek Canon we've interviewed uh Star
Trek actors like Wil Wheaton and
tignataro and everyone tells this story
which I'm sure you've heard
about how actors regardless of whether
we're talking about next generation or
Voyager or Discovery or or whatever that
when you give actors those phasers
and you have them Act
they unconsciously all go pew pew pew
pew pew pew
like they have to be told repeatedly
stop saying pew stop saying that
we can see your lips I've you know I've
heard that's true of Star Wars too
though because I I talked to I talked to
Hayden Christensen a couple weeks ago
and he said he was saying you know oh
yeah it's hard to not it's you know to
not make the noise you know because you
know but yes I he that he and McGregor
had said that a lot with it
the lightsaber too that's right yeah
exactly yeah how can you not make the
mouth noises so Ryan I talked at the
beginning of the show about my
epic 70s science fiction collection
here's here's another one Paul Anderson
a circus of Hells that's great
um these are so good oh my God this one
is expensive back in the day this was 11
1970 first edition
so many uh great science fiction I I I
grew up I I nursed from the teat of
Science Fiction as I was watching all of
those amazing Star Trek reruns through
the 70s like I feel like it made me who
I am I feel like Science Fiction and
Fantasy
um all of those stories made me the
actor that I am the human being that I
am gave me the mind that I have and you
were thick in this you were you were in
it you were in it to win it you are Mr
science fiction so can you talk a little
bit from your expertise and feel free to
just be a colossal wind bag at this
point so I think you know it's
impossible to separate America from
American Science Fiction especially over
the last 100 years 110 years H.T Wells
aside a couple of Brits but mostly
American why is it important take us
through the History of Science Fiction
especially at how it interweaves with
American culture and society and
identity well you're right that it is
uniquely American and it's not really
until the 70s that you start to see a
Resurgence of uh British sci-fi writers
um I actually was just reading a
scholarly book that was written in the
70s that was a survey of Science Fiction
up until that point
um and the author went out of his way in
the introduction to say I'm not talking
about British Science Fiction because
American Science Fiction is the birth of
Science Fiction as we know it and that's
because it started in the pulp magazines
in the 20s and 30s right and so that is
where science fiction essentially comes
from as we know it now
um and then what you had is you had and
Hugo gernsbach was the kind of founder
of um astounding um and then you had um
John Campbell take over astounding and
John Campbell was this guy who decided
that science fiction was going to be
taken a little bit more seriously and he
was going to be a really Hands-On editor
and he basically made the career of
Isaac Asimov
and Robert Heinlein right and he later
made the career of Frank Herbert
um now John Campbell is also a really
controversial guy because he got
um sort of a little bit more
conservative when he got into the 60s
and you know we think of Science Fiction
as this sort of Bastion of sort of like
Progressive ideas but in the 40s and 50s
it was just kind of pro-technology
apology which was kind of politically
neutral you know which I think a lot of
people kind of forget so Robert Heinlein
for example Rayne you just showed me a
Starship Troopers you know like he was
basically a Libertarian you know but
then he wrote A Stranger in a Strange
Land which was this like book about free
love and you know I grock you and all
this stuff so science fiction writers
were not one thing or another prior it
is it is kind of crazy sir to continue
please but it is kind of crazy and I
never really thought about this is the
same heinle this is about fascism by the
way that's right and and then uh
Stranger in a Strange Land is it it
became the Counter Culture kind of tome
it's that's what everyone was reading in
the 70s I loved that book to your point
you take something like stranger into
Strange Land and uh Starship Troopers
and they're like they're not written by
the same person they seem incongruous
um but so to answer your question was
uniquely American about science fiction
is right there is that you can have an
an author who was literally the
Hemingway of Science Fiction right like
Robert Hyland Robert Heinlein was this
anyway of of American Science Fiction he
was the biggest science fiction writer
of all time uh at at that time in the
60s but uh I think that that's what's
uniquely American is that you had a lot
of competing ideologies sort of crashing
into each other you pick up an issue of
astounding from the 60s and you'll have
something that seems you know sort of
kind of uh conservative and about sort
of space exploration and like a g whiz
kind of way but then you can have some
kind of meditative and and odd and Star
Trek's like that too right you've got
um writers like Harlan Ellison
um who was like this really you know he
was part of What's called the new wave
of of Science Fiction writers in the 60s
and 70s who was less interested in
technology and more interested in the
sort of like Humanity but then you've
got Robert block who wrote Psycho
writing episodes of the original Star
Trek 2. so like like that George Clayton
Johnson wrote the first aired episode of
Star Trek ever and he's famous for
co-authoring Logan's Run the novel
version of Logan's Run I have that oh
it's Wonder have you read it I haven't
read it but I have it oh it's great it's
the Logan's Run novel you well so you
guys like Rogan's Logan's Run I love it
yeah oh yeah yeah so but so in the novel
it's 21.
it's 30 in the movie right that you die
you got yeah you know like um it's a lot
more hardcore that you uh and for folks
who don't know Logan's Run the idea is
that you live in a future Society where
uh everyone you party your your ass off
and you have an amazing time but you
have to die at the age of 30 and you're
you're hoping to be chosen to be able to
live on but no one has ever chosen to
live on
um it's a world of plastic surgery and
debauchery for the youthful yeah so but
the novel version code co-authored a
very slender novel co-authored by uh uh
William Nolan and George Clayton Johnson
it's wonderful you die at 21 in the
novel and you know how in the movie
there's like there is no sanctuary in
the novel there is
and it's in space it's great but it's a
great I wish that somebody would do the
novel
but again anyway that the different
variety of voices in American Science
Fiction from the 40s through the 70s is
why science fiction is so reflective of
America and reflective of everything
that our culture struggles with and
still struggles with because science
fiction created this unique place where
all of those extreme viewpoints somehow
could end up in the same publication or
in the case of The Twilight Zone or the
outer limits
um or One Step Beyond or Star Trek they
could also end up on the same TV show
you know I say this in the book but like
if you put all the people that wrote for
Star Trek just the Original Series in
one room
they would not be able to agree on what
science fiction was what Star Trek was
you know um I mean Sherry Lewis who
invented Lamb Chop wrote an episode of
the original Star Trek which one no way
the lights of zatar uh pull it up on
your remind me remind me of that one
reminds me the third it's a third season
episode
and it is a lower budget lower budget no
budget so it's it is about literal
lights that sort of contain ascensions
in them
um oh yeah the point is is you got
Sherry Lewis
writing on the same show as Harlan
Ellison you know I don't know of any
other
show that's like that you know
now a word from our sponsor better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life well that's how our brains
work so why don't we treat them that way
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and Care into keeping them
healthy there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain like learning a
new language or taking power naps
there's also better help online therapy
you know these are rough times it's
covid it's a lot of political chaos
there's a lot of pressures
um you know I'm a big fan of therapy and
I use my weekly therapy session to
really dig deep to help give me tools
that I need to not only survive the
modern world but to thrive in it
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy you could be matched
with a therapist in under 48 Hours
metaphysical milkshake listeners you can
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better
help.com slash milkshake
you know folks in all of the craziness
going on in all of the pressure
sometimes our fun time gets pushed to
the bottom of the priority list you know
what I mean and we we have to wait for
that fabled free time to do things that
really bring a smile to our face how
often uh dear milkshakers do you really
let yourself have some hard-earned fun
well whatever your answer is you know
what forget it you deserve way way more
so add some joy to your daily routine
with the delightful game best fiends the
puzzle Adventure game you will not be
able to put down trust me I have worked
my way up slavishly diligently with a
tremendous amount of fun up to level 85
I'm in the dusty dungeon okay I've been
powering up my fiends upgrading my
fiends to take on the evil slugs and the
challenge and the fun just keeps
increasing level after level best fiends
is a free to download mobile puzzle game
with thousands of exciting levels for
new adventures and challenges every
single time you play there are dozens of
unique fiends to collect so you can
customize your team of fiends to defeat
those medicine slugs power up your
favorite fiends to new levels for even
more powerful skills and watch them
transform as they get stronger and with
offline play okay you'll never be
stranded without fun even if you lose
your internet connection brand new
events and challenges pop up all year
round so you've always got a chance to
earn exclusive in-game items characters
and rewards you've earned your fun time
go to the app store or Google play to
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five that's friends without the r best
fiends
so you bring up a very important point
about science fiction one that we talked
about earlier and one that you know
everyone mentions when you talk about
science fiction and why it's so popular
and important and culturally relevant
which is that the best science fiction
is the kind that uses the trappings of
the future to explore the issues of the
present right science fiction when it's
at its best is essentially a mirror
right a future mirror for present
Society but it also works the other way
too where you know not only does science
fiction reflect Society like you say and
all the changes if you look at like you
know from the 40s to the 70s and how
science fiction you know has shifted but
it also science fiction also has the
power to change society right it it has
a it has a deep influence uh an an
affect upon our society it often creates
new technologies right uh we all know
about that but it also changes our
morality the way that we that we think
about ourselves and our place in the
world tell us a little bit about the the
role that science fiction plays not just
in reflecting Society but in changing
Society I guess I should know that that
how to answer that question I think that
like I think that for me
um what it does is it allows people
to see where they're wrong
I guess in this like really obvious way
I was thinking about Blade Runner the
other day I'm going to answer this
question by talking about Blade Runner
if that's okay
all day if you want to all right so
Blade Runner just had its uh a big
anniversary just had its 40th
anniversary came out in 1982 same month
as The Wrath of Khan uh it didn't stand
a chance at the box office right
Blade Runner is a ostensibly about a a
bounty hunter hunting down Escape robots
who are basically Killers right
um and they're no good but then in the
end of the movie uh Roy Baddie uh
doesn't kill Deckard he saves him and
then he does that wonderful uh
rudderhauer Soliloquy monologue yeah
life tears tears in the rain yeah right
yeah I've seen things a few people
wouldn't believe and then he died which
he wrote by the way he wrote that model
ad-lib ad-lib um and then he dies and
then you the viewer are left wondering
who the bad guy was was it Harrison Ford
or was it Roy Batty I've seen things you
people wouldn't believe well what does
that mean well it means that our
perspective uh is is [ __ ] up
and that that movie tells you at the end
that your entire perspective has been
[ __ ] up on this and that this guy
who's been killing these people might
actually also be one of them he might be
a replicant so his reason his racial
reason for killing them is absurd and
that this other guy who was we thought
was a murderer and a terrible person is
care is capable of this deep empathy so
there's one example and then you go okay
then how I have to live my life
differently because I can't end up on a
rooftop like Deckard and have some and
and feel like a piece of [ __ ] yeah you
know because I think that's what that
movie does is it makes you wonder about
that so you know Star Trek does this in
very on the nose ways right you know we
know when Star Trek or you know not
always
um but it does it in very you know
kind of it's famous for doing it and on
the nose ways I should say
um you know Kirk in the taste of
Armageddon my favorite episode of the
original series ever
I don't we we make a choice we don't
have to kill today you know the idea
that there is a choice so I think that
the way that science fiction
changes us is that it creates a
hyperbole
big hyperbole pushes everything out
makes it really big and then it
demonstrates how we can make different
choices and so I think you know one of
the jokes I've been making about the
book is I cannot imagine Barack Obama
being president if he wasn't a Star Trek
fan because people he talked about how
he loves Spock and then people compared
him to spock when he was elected how do
How does Barack Obama not how does he
become Barack Obama if he didn't like
Star Trek
and he didn't have that kind of you know
I can't prove that but he did talk about
Spock enough during his presidency and
his love of Star Trek to really make you
wonder if Star Trek didn't exist
would Barack have have kind of developed
that spockish that spockish Swagger but
you know like in the way that Obama
makes a decision wait you're saying that
that Barack Obama had a bro had a
spockish Swagger is that said that you
know I joked about it yeah but he was
like journalists said this all the time
yeah that he was that he was stoic and
that he made his that I I almost feel
like
the people when they play Spock now I
love Ethan Peck's performance Zachary
quintos I always am reminded of Obama
um you know like so that's my that's
that's my hyperbolic uh example there
what I love it you're right you're
absolutely right though that that one
thing about Star Trek in the sense that
like it's so especially the the TOs and
TNG were so on the nose with their with
their that's the original series and the
new generation for those listening thank
you yeah uh you know it's like but
you're black on one side and white on
the other and he's black on the left and
white on the right you are the same whoa
so dude yeah well you know what's funny
though is that to defend Star Trek for
its subtleties I say this in the book
but people talk about that episode a lot
let there'll be let that be your last
Battlefield
uh written by Lee Cronin which was
actually a pen name for Gene Kuhn who
was the Star Trek story editor from the
first two seasons but that episode is is
ridiculous and kind of hard to watch now
but then you've got the Man Trap the
first episode ever aired and Michelle
Nichols is just casually speaking
Swahili
Now American audiences didn't have
characters speaking Swahili yeah with no
Fanfare before that so Star Trek was
subtle in those other ways um but Walter
Koenig said something so smart is he was
just like yeah but it's not always just
about the stories of Star Trek and I
think this extends to science fiction
he's like it's about like what people
see in terms of like he said just seeing
all the faces of Chekhov and Sulu and
Uhura together in unity
was more important and I think that
there's something about that too is that
Star Trek gets it gets a bad rap
sometimes for being over the top at
least the original series does but there
was a lot of subtlety the fact that they
they were just even there yeah and the
fact they were speaking Swahili and and
you know and uh that that is that's big
and that that's another way that you
know I don't think that that would have
happened on a sitcom no and like the
this is this brings up the point that I
was trying to make is that it's not the
influence that sci-fi has on
um Society isn't just about you know
technology because everyone talks about
that a lot you know that like a lot of
our technological advances a lot of our
best scientists and inventors were all
like Star Trek nerds and how the
influence that it's had but but it's
also on morality a lot and we joke about
you know the the sort of on the nose
morality of it but listen this it was uh
a bit of a challenge in the time that it
uh that It first aired you know and it
did make people think differently about
some of their uh assumptions you know
about other people of other races other
other
um uh ethnicities or or you know a lot
of Science Fiction has made people think
differently about the environment and
about our our you know the morality of
taking care of the planet uh so it has
this kind of very interesting effect on
our society it's not just a mirror right
it's not just a mirror of our society it
does actually push us as a society to
change to be better to be worthy of the
often but not always utopian
view uh of society that a lot of uh the
best sci-fi presents us for me one of
the things that science fiction did for
America is brought out the best of
America we talk a lot about the failings
of America you know and there are many
there are two numerous dimension
racism materialism you know oppression
uh you know the colonialization and it
goes imperialism goes on and on and on
but
um that nothing beats science fiction
for that pure
burst of adrenalized imaginative
optimism that came from science fiction
and again like Reza said not just the
technology oh there's time travel and
there's devices that allow you to do X Y
and Z space travel
Etc but
um the way it challenges us
um morally to it to examine ourselves
and not and no one did that better than
Star Trek why do you think that is well
I think that it is because
Roddenberry Gene Roddenberry the creator
of Star Trek intelligently hired writers
of Science Fiction prose and those
people had been do had been cramming
morality Tales into short stories for
years you know and so and a lot of them
you know Harlan Ellison is a good
example he only wrote one episode of the
original series
um city on the edge of forever you know
in which Kirk Perhaps Perhaps the best
episode have to make an impossible
Choice an ethical dilemma that can only
exist in science fiction
um in which you know a innocent social
worker uh named Edith Keeler has to die
in order for a war uh to not um you know
for the Nazis not to invade America you
know they did a kind of a version of it
in the strange new Worlds Finale that
just aired in which Pike has to see a
future in which you know he is the wrong
guy in in the wrong place even though
he's trying to make the right decision
but Harlan Ellison has
billions of those short stories crammed
into magazines and short story
collections before he starts writing for
Star Trek I talked to Norman spinrad
who's this wonderful science fiction
writer from the 60s who wrote the
Doomsday Machine of the in the original
series another another name you just
made up yeah uh Norman spin rad he's in
his he's in his 80s he lives in he lives
in Paris I talked to him for an hour on
the phone on uh about how he got hired
and he got hired because Roddenberry had
read some of his pros this guy had never
written a teleplay before
Ron Berry said hey I want I like I like
your sci-fi I want you to write a
teleplay he had to call Harlan Ellison
say how do you write a teleplay so why
does that matter well these it matters
because they came from a tradition of
literature
and so they had to be able to have
characters and morality plays in their
stories before they were doing it Rod
Sterling was good at this in the
Twilight Zone right he hired Richard
Matheson who wrote a lot of the great
Twilight Zone episodes that people loved
um but those writers I think were so
experienced with creating those sorts of
morality plays that by the time Gene
Roddenberry created this kind of vehicle
and spinrad basically said that he
believed that Roddenberry creating Star
Trek was Bob Dylan going electric for
science fiction he's like this is a
great analogy that's great that was from
Norman spinrad that is not mine he gave
that to me he's like he's like what
happened was is that before everybody
who read science fiction it was just
people that read the magazines in the
books and they went to the conventions
and it was Tiny then you got Star Trek
and suddenly it's in millions and
millions and millions of American homes
and suddenly everybody knows what a
doppelganger is and a clone and and time
travel and War because those writers
were capable of that hyperbole but they
had to be able to sell those stories and
make them stick
um
that I think that that's why is that
Star Trek had some literary chops and
people forget that they're like oh Gene
Roddenberry sat back and Gene Kuhn who
was a great scriptwriter but they hired
a lot of really talented people
guys I just got my brand new bag of
coffee in the mail from Trade coffee
this one is called Blue Moon it's got
these incredible hints of milk chocolate
and Mandarin and Honeysuckle and it's
exactly my kind of coffee why do I know
that because before Trade coffee sent it
to me they actually gave me this
incredible coffee quiz it asked me all
these really fascinating questions about
like when do I like to drink coffee how
do I like to drink coffee what are my
favorite notes when I drink coffee and
you know I'm filling this thing out
thinking why not this is kind of fun
I've never really thought about these
things and somehow the Geniuses at Trade
coffee managed to send me every month a
bag of coffee usually I've never even
heard of these Coffee Roasters they're
from like all over the planet that is
exactly what I was going for and that is
the magic of Trade coffee right right
now trade is offering new subscribers a
total of 30 off your first order plus
free shipping when you go to
drinktrade.com milkshake that's more
than 40 cups of coffee for free get
started by taking their quiz at
drinktrade.com milkshake and let trade
find you a coffee you'll love that's
drinktrade.com milkshake for thirty
dollars off
do you think however that science
fiction in its attempt to not just kind
of reflect you know the present reality
but to as we've been talking about drive
it to move it towards uh you know a
different kind of reality whether it's
by showing us a dystopian world that you
know could be our future if we don't do
X Y and Z or a utopian world that could
be our future if we do XYZ like a lot of
a lot of Science Fiction kind of
presents that that uh moral choice
whether explicitly or not but do you
feel like sometimes especially nowadays
um when we're confronted with very real
uh you know dystopian uh present not
just future
um
do you feel that sometimes it can be a
little too real like what's the danger
of getting a very a little too deeply
mired in uh present conflicts like I'm
thinking about just since we're already
on the Star Trek thing
you mentioned strange new worlds this is
the newest spin-off right in this season
of strange new worlds uh where you know
for you Trek fans were like 40 years
before the first contact with Vulcans
right that it comes on the on the heels
of World War III
um we learn that uh this sort of great
World War III this American Civil War
that you know has been a part of Star
Trek lore for from the very very
beginning begins on January 6th
I mean they certainly make that
implication yeah right they certainly
make that implication yeah and and I
wonder so this this is my question which
is like is that a little too close for
comfort I think that science fiction in
general and Star Trek in specific is
generally best when it's taking risks
right Kirk said in the original series
risk is our business right
um I think that science fiction that
plays it safe
is generally forgotten or at the very
least is just science fiction that is
using sci-fi trappings
you know to to have fun and there's
nothing wrong with that you know
Guardians of the Galaxy would be a great
example of that right there's nothing
wrong with Guardians of the Galaxy but
it's just a science fiction setting
right it's not particularly
um contemplative you know
um about it's not particularly about
anything other than like these bad these
are people are bad and these people are
good and there's a reluctant hero you
know and that's fine and that's also you
know kind of describes the majority of
Star Wars as as well which is why people
always debate like well Star Wars really
science fiction would you know and I
don't know get to that you know I don't
know
um but um so I think that like can it go
too far I don't know if you go back and
watch the Next Generation the first
episode of The Next Generation encounter
at farpoint in 1987. it's the same [ __ ]
Q is telling Picard about World War III
and how bad it is and there's a soldier
who's like addicted to drugs that's
being drugged up
and there's a courtroom where they're
you know that you know and that was 87
you know that was like the same your
RoboCop comes out right and like it's
almost like Picard and the crew are like
in a Robocop sort of a horrible dystopia
which we're told is their past but our
future still so it might not have been
as on the nose as say strange new worlds
you know referencing January 6th but I
mean you know Kirk and Bones talked
about Nam in in a private little war you
know outright you know like they they
talk about Vietnam you know so I don't
know like I I think that if you don't
take the risk to try to like get those
specific political
or or
current events talking points into the
story that I don't know really why
you're even trying you know if you read
like some Philip K dick novels
there's like the a book called uh flow
my tears the policeman said
it's a great book it's really weird one
of the best titles of all time yeah
isn't it yeah I found a first edition at
a local library what library just uh
it's in South Portland Maine I live in
Portland Maine I'm making a phone call
right now okay yeah
very seriously eBay quarters of okay yep
ebook has some sort of Philip K dick
imagines this sort of future and it's
not even the central part of the story
but where there's just been a mass
elimination of a lot of different races
and he talks about it in a way that is a
little bit awkward now when you read it
because it feels a little bit like I'm
not sure if this white bearded white guy
should have been writing about this
right but
at the same time no other science
fiction writer was writing about it in
that way at that time other than you
know um Octavia Butler but I think that
the point is that Philip K dick took
some risks in his novels and those risks
got through to an audience that may not
have otherwise been aware of some of
these issues so I think that and I don't
think that that's necessarily a
particularly good Philip K dick novel
but I think it's great that he wrote it
and that he took the risk to write it
and so I think that I think that science
fiction is a genre that you can fail
right like you can you can try it and
fail and that's it but you gotta take
those big swings like you said did you
read Ministry of the future by any
chance yeah so Kim Kim Stanley Robinson
great science fiction writer
um he uh wrote this book dear listeners
called a Ministry of the future that is
was one of the most difficult books I've
ever read in my life it was so hard I
was uh Spellbound by it but it was also
really hard for me to read because it's
about climate change and it's and it
starts off with one of the most
heart-stopping chapters you've ever read
in your life where in India in the near
future
um the temperature reaches a point where
human life cannot survive
a combination of dew point and humidity
and temperature
um where you will literally
suffocate in the Heat and millions of
people die in a heat wave and all of a
sudden the world wakes up to like oh
[ __ ] what are we gonna do now wow 2028
2028 2029 yeah exactly okay keep going
so but it's just it's terrifying and it
was so it's such an important book but
it's uh it is also too real really
challenging because it hits a little too
close to home what do you think
well I think that science fiction is
able to get a little bit more specific
now than perhaps it could have in the
60s or 70s right so the the flip side of
that is Dune in which Frank Herbert had
all these ecological messages about
climate change and like how a planet uh
environment gets all screwed up but he
kind of talked himself out of putting a
lot of that actually in the novel in
that earlier versions of the novel had
even more of the climatologist in them
and then of course Dune comes out and
it's hailed as this big book about
ecology and that and it gets on all
these lists but if you read the book
itself that stuff isn't really the story
right the adventure narrative is the
story The Coming of Age story is is the
plot
so he was kind of smart to
put that inside of a different kind of
narrative right but I think contemporary
science fiction doesn't have to sort of
hide behind like Joseph Campbell Heroes
Journey stuff I think they're able to do
like what Kim Stanley Robinson does
because we're so close to the apocalypse
there's a great book or even like Mad
Max feels like not so far off
necessarily there's a great book um that
came out in I want to say 2014 by a
friend of mine named Elena Grayden is a
science fiction novel called the word
exchange this was like when smartphones
were just getting popular but she writes
this book about like kind of a near
future New York in which smartphones
basically become telepathic and then
like these addictive games get
introduced on everybody's phones and
then suddenly everybody's getting
aphasic and they can't actually
communicate and words are getting like
removed from online dictionaries because
they're no longer relevant to this
algorithm that's kind of controlling
everybody's telepathic phone device it's
one of the greatest science fiction
novels written in the past 20 years it
was very it was kind of under the radar
uh the word exchange maybe because the
title was didn't grab people by Elena
Grayden
um but that book is really really you
know up to the minute in terms of like
how
technology and social media
changes our emotional Viewpoint and
messes with our lives Gary steingart did
it in super sad true love story yeah
2010. yeah you read that yeah you know
and I think that that like you know that
a lot of his like fake he made a lot of
fake Internet speak in that book and now
it feels quaint you know what I mean but
he wrote that was an up to the minute
book of him sort of predicting okay here
what are all these Trends you know
um yeah yeah now it already feels
outdated it feels like 12 years ago I
think that the answer then sort of is
that like the stuff that feels very up
to the minute now Kim Stanley Robinson
the opening of strange new worlds it
actually ages better than you think
sometimes
um you know I think there's kind of a
paradox there it's the same thing with
Blade Runner right like all of that Neo
future 80s you know it's set in 2019 and
now you watch it and it weirdly feels
timeless
you know you mentioned Star Wars earlier
and uh it's interesting because I knew
JJ Abrams threw the Grapevine and
when he was going to reboot Star Wars I
contacted him and said hey me and my
friend Reza you know we really love
religions and spirituality and we'd love
to talk to you about you know the
mythology of Star Wars we brought along
a Gotham Chopra Deepak chopra's uh son
who's uh he's been a guest on our show
um he's got a very successful production
company
um and we came in and met with the the
screenwriter and the producers and
talked about the mythology of Star Wars
the spiritual uh mythology we were
really excited to dig into you know the
the hero myth at the center of it the
Messiah story you know the the the force
and uh and the Mystery of that and the I
mean the Jedi or priests like why do we
always forget the fact that the Jedi are
priests that they live in a temple that
there's like a a religion behind this so
like we were like let's let's because
that's slow that slowly got sapped out
of it it started very spiritual the
original Star Wars is is a spiritual
movie and then it gradually became about
mitochlorians you know explaining the
force right so so none of what we said
and emphasized and underlined to JJ and
the gang was utilized in any way shape
or form in fact he went the opposite
direction got even more kind of
science-based than George Lucas
um and I get it that that's fine but you
take out the mystery of Star Wars and it
becomes action adventures with it they
might as well be westerns
um and it's not really science fiction
uh it might as well be a western and
instead of spaceships it would be I
don't know carriages or ships or
something like that
um but so my question for you is why
does Star Wars suck so much worse than
Star Trek oh talk about Civil War here
we go it's very easy I can answer this
for you very easily I really like
a lot of the new Star Wars shows and I
like a lot of the people that work on
them and I was really happy you have to
say that and you know it however
however in 2020
the opening of the Mandalorian season
two featured
um
everybody killing
a monster because
they couldn't figure out anything else
to do other than just just kill it just
blow it up from the they like go inside
and blow it up from the inside the week
prior was the season premiere of Star
Trek Discovery season three in which a
very similar worm-like monster is
threatening uh David ajala's character
book and taniqua Martin Green's uh
Michael Burnham and you know what they
do they make friends with that monster
and that those episodes aired uh uh that
hope is you part one
um of Discovery season three and the
first episode of Mandalorian season so
they aired like within week of each
other
and they both have giant worm monsters
on this in the sand kind of ripped off
from Dune and in Star Trek they they
make peace literally he empathizes with
it book empathizes with it and in the
Mandalorian
all those very talented people were like
let's just figure out how to blow this
thing up and make it really gross and
just really kill it let's just kill it
and I think that's it to me that's it
and I love and I like Star Wars a lot
and I like writing about it and I like
thinking about it but that to me is it
is that there's no other way that that
you can that is the difference between
the writing and and the other answer to
that question is that Star Trek is
mostly about adults and Star Wars is
mostly about coming of age stories and
in Star Trek generally speaking the
people are already
as a child I fought Picard and Riker and
Kirk and Cisco were great because they
were grown-ups
and they were they were doing their
career they were just weren't you know
and then in Star Wars it's kind of like
oh you gotta now you'll become who
you're supposed to be and then the
story's over you know Star Trek's like
okay
I've never heard anyone
compare and contrast Star Trek and Star
Wars that well and and and explain why I
and rain and I think a lot of like true
sci-fi fans uh think that there's no
argument about which one is better like
Star Wars and Star Trek like there's no
comparison between the two let's get to
your thesis your thesis is how the
making and remaking and remaking and
remaking and remaking and remaking of
Star Trek uh changed the world so how
how exactly like technologically
speaking morally sociologically like how
give away the thesis to your book right
now so people don't have to buy it it's
funny because every review of the book
sort of questions whether or not I've
earned the subtitle like that tends to
be the um the attack
um and I think that
um something my editor and I talked
about is is that
it changed the world because it changed
people and it changed the way people
think about morality in in relationship
to science and in relationship to these
outlandish Concepts and there are
specific examples of that uh you know
Greenpeace donations go up during the
the run of the Voyage Home in movie
theaters in 1986-1987. that happened you
know
um Leonard Nimoy put Greenpeace
strategies into a Star Trek movie
there's an on the nose one
um right there the first Star Trek movie
that was uh screened in Russia
um before Star Wars
um
uh Nichelle Nichols single-handedly
recruited black and uh women astronauts
to the space shuttle program right that
would not have been in the space shuttle
program otherwise we interviewed one of
them we interviewed one of them who just
flat out yeah it was it was Michelle
Nichols but I mean you know that
happened she worked with them she
trained to be an astronaut to do the um
the recruitment uh so that happened you
know science fiction was brought into
the mainstream which led to Star Wars
and led to all these all these films in
the 80s I don't think without Star Trek
and the fan culture of the 70s that any
of that any of the 80s movies or late
70s movies really could have happened
um they I mean the only other
long-running show other than Star Trek
was Doctor Who and Doctor Who never
really broke into America until the
early odds right it created it was the
Dylan going electric moment it put
science fiction tropes and ideas into
millions and millions of American homes
Star Trek has a lot of literature inside
of it and it I think that it
repopularized some literature and my
example of this that I always give is I
used to do a Moby Dick marathon in New
York City a lot of writers would do this
in New York City where people read the
entirety of Moby Dick over the course of
three days
and every single time I did this I did
it three times
whenever the reader who was doing the
famous scene where you know from the
hell's heart
I stabbed at thee for Hate's sake three
people in the audience would always go
come on because people were introduced
to Moby Dick I was introduced to Moby
Dick by through the Wrath of Khan I
interviewed Patrick Stewart this year um
for Picard season two and ice like you
know my first Christmas Carol was
listening to you sir Patrick on
um a cassette tape that I had of his
one-man show that was released in night
in the 90s and um he was like really and
I was like that's I did uh I did The
Tempest with him on Broadway how was
that I saw him do the the Christmas
carol like before he took it to Broadway
like his practice run
but I mean like but I think that like if
you're a kid and you're obsessed with
Star Trek in 1992 like I was suddenly
you now like Dickens yeah exactly
yeah
and suddenly now you like Shakespeare
and suddenly now you like you know all
this you know Milton and you know all
the and so that is the other thing is
that it's this gateway drug into
literature Sherlock Holmes you know
Nicholas Meyer puts all the Sherlock
Holmes stuff um into the Wrath into the
Undiscovered Country Hamlet
um you know I don't know if I would have
gotten into being a big lover of serious
literature if it weren't for Trek and I
don't think I'm alone there so finally
we want to just kind of sum this up by
saying where do we go
looking at where we are right now we
reference January 6th we referenced
climate change Kim Stanley Robinson and
um
so many deep difficult issues where does
science fiction
need to take us now what is what is the
future what is what is your Clarion call
to the science fiction writers and
creators out there of what what is
needed to move us forward from this
genre it's a good question
um I think that
imagine I think science fiction that
imagines a
future
in which the role of Technology
feels less artificial
you know I think that that is something
that I I was reading an essay a friend
of mine sent me who works at Nasa today
about
how we always view technology as being
in opposition to our Humanity
and how a lot of Science Fiction is
written like that you know
um Battlestar Galactica you know various
you know the Terminator right like you
know technology destroys us I'm
definitely concerned about my iPhone
screen addiction I'm concerned by how
much my daughter looks at screens
but you know it seems like people have a
really healthy relationship with
technology and Star Trek and then in
Dune and Star Wars they're they're they
actually kind of have a healthy
relationship there too you know they
they need the hyperdrive but it's not
like they're obsessed with video games
or social media or anything like that so
I feel like there's got to be a way that
science fiction can present
present a future in which there's not so
much technological strife and that the
science fiction could be about something
else
that isn't just about tech you know you
know because even Star Trek does this
right like they need their they need
their technology
like the warp drive and stuff to get
going but then the Borg that's too much
technology that's all technology you
know and so it's like sort of like and
it's like yeah but you guys also like
are really reliant on artificial gravity
and all this other stuff that's really
unnatural and like you go to the
Holodeck and Rikers having sex with
Holograms and you know that's not
healthy right like you know don't those
Holograms have rights you know
um you know I so and you know we kind of
compartmentalize it because that's what
science fiction does
um but you know I was talking to Anson
Mount for Esquire a couple days ago and
he was talking about how and rain as an
actor you probably can relate to this
about how just being at a Sound Stage
just means you're not outside enough
um and he was just like I want to be
outside more you know but I'm on a Star
Trek show so I'm inside too much you
know and I was thinking about like I was
like wow if I get off this call I'm
gonna go outside with my daughter
because I need to be outside more so I
think that science fiction needs to get
outside and needs to be more about
technology not being this thing that
confines
um Humanity but but perhaps a more kind
of a more hopeful like an asthma ending
right like the end of iRobot uh in a
story called The evitable uh uh conflict
robots are like have taken over but it's
fine because they were programmed well
and they're good yeah and they're kind
and benevolent and I'm just like I'm
like and there's not a lot of that you
know right there's not a lot of us and
what you're saying is maybe offering
some hope you know I think harboring
some hope but specifically around that
around that about not just going into
like I love black mirror but not not
everything's got to be that not
everything's gonna be like that so I
would say more technological hope I just
love that and and I think you know
looking at
this question that that rain asked which
is like what kind of sci-fi do we need
right now like looking at this world
that we live in now and and the world
that's about to come like what kind of
sci-fi do we need I think one not just
that that integrates technology you know
Into The Human Experience in a in a
realistic and non-threatening way but
one in which
we are that technology where it's about
like the the human ability is is
Unchained right that that is the kind of
of sci-fi that I would love to see right
now
folks the the book again uh phasers on
stun how the making and remaking of Star
Trek changed the world what's your
previous book to this one with the funny
name uh Luke Skywalker can't read and
other geeky truths
so I it has been such a pleasure geeking
out with you I really feel I could go on
for hours and just continue this
conversation I feel like we need uh this
should be its entire podcast should be
about just kind of uh philosophically
speaking about science fiction you know
I'm not sure there's a pod like that so
um not one
that's this fun thanks for thanks for
being here appreciate it it was great
live long and prosper
live long and prosper Ryan
well
what do you think rain can sci-fi save
us I mean are we are we doomed I feel
like you know the answer is maybe I
think it has to I mean who else is going
to save us what else
there's answers there there's a lot of
answers in science fiction that's right
what else is Gonna Save Us like what
else do we have here you know
I mean at the very least what sci-fi
gives romantic comedies yes
well romantic comedies save us I just
feel like what sci-fi the best sci-fi
will offer us is a vision
of a possible future right and if it
hits us at that emotional level
then it can actually affect our decision
making that's not a joke I mean I I
think it's a real thing I think people
can be moved by emotional stories about
the future the near future the distant
future that then compels them to act
differently to make different choices I
know this because it happened to me I
know it's happened to you so yeah I
think sci-fi can save us
yeah well there you have it folks
science fiction can save us what do you
think we'd love to hear from you uh you
can reach us on all the social media
channels uh at Reza Aslin at Rayne
Wilson on Twitter at metamilk podcast on
Instagram
uh at metaphysical milkshake let us know
your life's big questions let us know
your thoughts about science fiction how
it has changed and affected your life
and how it might change and affect the
life of humanity moving forward we would
love to take your questions and weave
them into a future episode and also
folks we've Gonna Have a book giveaway
five of these suckers phasers on stun
leave us a positive review on Apple
podcasts take a screenshot of it send it
to us at our at our email address which
is metaphysical castmedia.com that's
cast with a K first five
get sent a copy of this magnificent
nerdfest and you know what in your
review
tell us your favorite sci-fi series or
show or book or movie is it Dune is it
Battlestar Galactica is it a rival that
was one of my recent absolute number
like that goes in my Pantheon even
though it's only a couple of years old
uh is it Doctor Who you know where do
you land on this Star Trek versus Star
Wars uh argument we want to know you can
also remember to subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake YouTube channel
and you can sort of see our beautiful
faces every week and until then we will
see you next time
thanks for tuning in folks live long and
prosper
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rain Wilson Reza Aslan and
Colin Thompson it is produced by Safa
samasade yazd Eris Lane Mick damaria
Hashem South and DJ lubel cast media is
the production and distribution partner
original music by Jeff Tang
[Music]
[Music]
his agent was a guy named lurten
blessing game who represented a big
science fiction writers which is why
you're making up all these names
you know what I had I had to call I had
to call a California research library to
get letters from blessing game and Frank
Herbert
um but no no that's a real person uh
yeah they all have great names right
asmov you know like like I was thinking
about Bradbury they've all got great
names
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
YouTube channel thank you